künstliche intelligenz ki ist großartig
und macht uns in vielen bereichen das
leben sehr viel leichter doch experten
und expertinnen warnen davor dass
computer schon bald eine echte
intelligenz entwickeln und somit in der
lage sind sich immer weiter selbst zu
verbessern dann würden sie menschliche
gehirne bei weitem übertrumpfen und
somit vielleicht sogar das ende der
menschheit bedeuten können wir dieses
horrorszenario abwenden und eine super
kontrollierbar gestalten damit sie uns
zumindest freundlich gesinnt ist alles
zu den gefahren und risiken einer
möglichen super gau jetzt bei pixum
science fiction
hier gibt's täglich faszinierendes heinz
videos abonniert den kanal nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts herzlich willkommen
und danke für euren dem vorschlag aus
der telekom community link ist in der
video beschreibung und am ende des
videos künstliche intelligenz ist uns
menschen längst nicht nur in vielen
bereichen besonders nützlich sondern
auch jetzt schon überlegen wie
beispielsweise dass die learnings system
einer amerikanischen firma das
menschliche emotionen schneller und auch
genauer als die meisten menschen
erkennen kann die ki kann sogar ein
echtes von einem falschen lächeln
unterscheiden die burning kann aber auch
ärzte team sehr effektiv unterstützen
beispielsweise können die algorithmen
lernen gesunde zellen von krebszellen zu
unterscheiden indem sie nach
verdächtigen merkmalen so und zudem kann
die ki aber auch nach wirkstoffen und
medikamenten cocktail suchen die
individuell für jeden patienten und jede
patientin am passendsten sind ibm hat
eine ki entwickelt die die dna
sequenzierung eines gehirntumors
schneller und zuverlässiger analysiert
hat als das gesamte team der
menschlichen experten und expertinnen
das sind aber nur zwei von mittlerweile
unzähligen bereichen in denen die ki im
wettstreit gegen uns menschen gewinnt
auch bei der wartung von maschinen und
bei der analyse von juristischen
klauseln sind uns neuronale netzwerke
mittlerweile haushoch überlegen doch
nicht nur das einige experten und
expertinnen sind sich sehr sicher dass
computer auch echte intelligenz
entwickeln könnten schon frank
rosenblatt der erfinder des ersten
künstlichen euroncap thron hat die
entstehung einer super ki vorhergesagt
seine visionen klang damals noch machst
1 fiction tour aber mit siri und so
weiter sind sie längst zur realität
geworden
zitat spätere personen werden in der
lage sein menschen zu erkennen und ihre
namen zu nennen gedruckte seiten
handgeschriebene briefe und sogar
sprachbefehle sind in reichweite
nur noch ein weiterer
entwicklungsschritt ein schwieriger
schritt ist notwendig damit ein gerät
rede in einer sprache hören und sofort
in rhede oder text einer anderen sprache
übersetzen kann
doch nicht nur das rosenblatt sagte
zudem voraus dass sich diese patronen
irgendwann einmal selbst reproduzieren
werden und sich sogar ihre eigenen
existenz bewusst werden seine vision
basiert auf der annahme dass das modell
der künstlichen neuronalen netze die
grundstruktur unseres gehirns beschreibt
der us zukunftsforscher raymond kurzweil
prognostiziert dass eine ki die
menschliche intelligenz etwa im jahr
2045 erstmals übersteigen wird der
philosophenweg posthum beschreibt die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass wir bis zum jahr
2075 eine maschine entwickelt haben die
uns kognitiv ebenbürtig ist mit 90
prozent diese könnte nicht nur
mindestens so gut wie wir strategisch
planen sondern auch logisch denken
kreativ sein und über eine intuition
verfügen solch eine ki wäre in der lage
sich immer weiter zu verbessern
diese verbesserte ki könnte sich dann
weiter optimieren
ein ewiger kreislauf der selbst
verbesserung also der fachleuten einen
eiskalten schauer über den rücken laufen
lässt weil das auch in wirklich ganz
kurzer zeit passieren kann wenn die
folge wäre eine intelligenz explosion
und solch eine künstliche super
intelligenz würde die menschliche
intelligenz komplett in den schatten
stellen auf uns würde solch eine ki
wahrscheinlich herabblicken wie wir
derzeit auf insekten wenn solche eine
super intelligenz erst einmal geschaffen
ist könnte sie nachträglich wohl auch
nicht mehr zu stoppen sein
in der fachsprache wird dies als
technologische singularität bezeichnet
es wäre die letzte erfindung der
menschheit doch es gibt auch andere
stimmen so zum beispiel jan alle kuhn er
ist der chef von facebook er ist der
überzeugung dass mit den derzeit
bekannten technologien keine super ki
entstehen kann
es handelt sich um ein
wissenschaftliches problem nicht um ein
technisches sagte kuhn es geht nicht
darum dass unsere
computer nicht schnell genug wären oder
die software ungeeignet uns fehlen
grundsätzliche prinzipien
somit wird es seiner meinung nach erst
einmal bei einer sogenannten schwachen
ki bleiben die eigenständig lernen kann
und sehr präzise und schnell ausgewählte
aufgaben erledigen kann eine starke
dagegen wäre in der lage ihr wissen
sogar zu transferieren
also ihr wissen von einer aufgabe auf
die nächste zu übertragen dabei könnte
sich die ki sogar eigenständig
verbessern dazu lag um das zu erreichen
benötigen wir computerprogramme die über
so etwas wie einen gesunden
menschenverstand verfügen irgendeine
form von allgemeiner intelligenz das ist
eben der große unterschied zwischen dem
lernverhalten von menschen und der ki
forschung menschen aber auch tiere sind
dazu in der lage anhand weniger daten zu
lernen und das wissen zu generalisieren
anders sieht der lernvorgang bei einem
ki system aus hier werden unzählige
texte fotos videos oder andere daten
benötigt damit das system auf einen
spezifischen anwendungsfall hin
optimiert werden kann
was aber klar ist ki entscheidungen
spielen schon jetzt eine sehr große
rolle in unserer gesellschaft und haben
somit auch immer stärkere auswirkungen
für das menschliche leben
expertinnen und experten weltweit
fordern deswegen schon seit längerer
zeit dass regeln für die nutzung von
künstlicher intelligenz aufgestellt
werden
es müssen antworten gegeben werden auch
fragen wie wollen wir menschen uns
einigen für welche zwecke ki verwendet
werden soll und für welche bereiche
nicht denn maschinen übernehmen schon
jetzt kognitive denkprozesse und könnten
somit auch für feindselige zwecke
eingesetzt werden beispielsweise für
automatisierte waffensysteme eine andere
herausforderung in diesem kontext ist
aber auch in diesem zusammenhang dass
neuronale netzwerke einer blackbox
ähneln
somit können berechnungen die am ende zu
einer entscheidungsfindung für nur
schwierig oder gar nicht nachvollzogen
werden
haben wir also jetzt bereits die
kontrolle in gewisser weise verloren bei
youtube zum beispiel kann einem niemand
mehr erklären warum ein video in den
trends landet und ein vergleichbares
nicht mit zügig einer möglichen super
intelligenz schlägt der philosophenweg
boss schon vor diese kontrollierbar zu
gestalten sodass sie uns menschen
zumindest freundlich gesinnt ist
beispielsweise
indem man dem supercomputer regeln ein
schreibt doch dafür wäre ja ein ganzer
moral katalog notwendig den eine ki dann
schematisch anwenden müsse effektiver
wäre es vielleicht aber auch der ki
die fähigkeit mitzunehmen selbst
moralische vorstellungen und ethische
werte zu entwickeln ist dies ein weg an
ermöglichen apokalypse zu entgehen
die vorstellung dass wir uns vielleicht
schon bald den moralischen werten einer
super gau ii unterwerfen müssen ist
dennoch reichlich gruselig mehr zum
thema gibt es hier ki die letzte
erfindung der menschheit anklicken
anschauen und in jedem fall raumzeit
lockt der zukunft abonnieren cooler
kanal und wenn ihr nie mehr ein video
verpassen wollt dann klickt ihr drauf
der unfassbare garantierte telegramm
newsletter bis dann bleibt dran moment
noch nicht geklickt jetzt aber